looking back on turning a short film
into a feature is there anything you
would do differently next time a lot of
stuff would I want my story to be each
year to be better I want my I want more
time I want to deal with yeah time is
the main main factor that I want to do
of course my next one I wanted to be
different a little bit still keep the
same signature and everything but just
doing in their direction but timewise
I'm planning to at least seven days more
just really take the time and less
location maybe this one was fine because
we have so much location and there's a
thing we spend a lot of time just
traveling like for example we shot
everything in South Lake City but then
we shot everything Salt Lake City then
we drove like six hours to st. George
then we go to the waterfall for a little
the scene of the waterfall we drove
that's a crazy story we drove for like
one hour in a big minivan in the Rockies
no Road no nothing just big rocks with a
mini land for one hour it was the
scariest thing ever and you can fall
there it's super high and we have to
drove one hour and then at one point we
had the waterfall it was just like a
shitty direction from Google hoping to
get it so it would have been dangerous
but it worked and we had the big
waterfall and it was beautiful but not
everyone just want to do that but I
think that's part of the fun I want to
have it as a part of an adventure
they are having fun the character is is
traveling it's a road trip Wow that's
what I'm doing I want to travel to I
want to go and you know do those kind of
stuff and feel the the adventure with
them that's what that's a whole point
that I want I don't want to shoot in
Montreal nothing that yet but because
it's my home you know I mean I want to
feel I want to discover the thing I want
to feel like when I was in the castle in
France it was fun it's an you sleep
there and so it's it's the road trip
itself was the road trip of the film but
yeah thrill to answer your question time
is the big big thing that I want more so
next time you because you said I'm sorry
23 days 23 - yeah
23 I would live to a good 30 maybe it's
too much
but I but at least I know that because
sometime it's we think that I wouldn't
want to do with we show that we shot a
lot of at night and then the next date
was that day so
the time shift something was hard for
actors that you sleep at 7:00 a.m. then
around 12:00 let's go back and you know
is some time people didn't have enough
time to relax so but timewise are the
big big things that I want to change for
the next one right so that's what you
would recommend to another filmmaker
let's suppose they have a short and
they're gonna turn it into a feature
just give yourself more time than you
think you need if you didn't go through
feature film before maybe you're not
gonna understand what time is you know
so I think you have to go your first
think that think you're doing the best
that you can and then you realize but if
you can expend in you know if you can
not rush it then yeah take all the time
that you need it's gonna make a
difference for the actor for yourself
you need to recharge a little bit at one
point and and it's gonna make your scene
I think better but if you don't have a
choice then make sure that it's it's
well balanced
you